>>> HELLO, EVERYONE, THANK
SO MH ME THIS M EDTFIELD THI
THTHLOPMTS IN THE JANUAR6t
INSURRECTION HAS NOW IA  T SECR
ICNTON JANUARY 5ththES AFTER TH
ERASING THOSXTS AFTEOFFICE REQU
G TO A
SOURCE, HE TOLE PANEE
SECRET SERVICE HASULLY
OPHISE D
DELETING ANY MALICIOUSLY
THE E FIRST TIMEE PANE
RANCH AGENCY
Z INNOW.
WHENA CA, D GS THE
EDIS FAST-MOVINGNLY LEARNED THEE
FUSION AUN
CRET SCET M JANUARY 5th D h AYS,
13th.
THAT I THE
INSPECWHH NDEN
WATCINN LO
ECRET SERVICE HANDLINGthTHORHAT
IED OS FROM THEE
.  AT LE
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY THATRES DEV.
WL Y ATAVRE
DATA WITHOUT BACKINGP YOURS --
GUMENTLARGELY ET SERVICERE
THIS S
SIGNATE EVENTSAN BE NE ENC
r: SUSE  THAT, ANDE'S ANN FOCIE.
AMF CONFUSION  EXPRESSINTHMEESST
MESSAGEST ARSUPPOST ANCT C AOTHS
D S GCHL                     G
OF JANUARY 6th, THOSE
AREN'T THE
SECRETER
STNT GOING TO
OOPERA
C
CHIEOFERVICEJANUARLECTHA U
0  RADIOSI
RECE BEENSU PLA RCOMMITTEE'SUBA
IN A ME
T ISSUITTEE CONTINUETO
SECRET SERVICE Ih.
OPERAT WHAES THAT
THEM.E ULHAVE NEEA RERD THOSE
REBEPU TO THE
THA
TSUSPICION, LOFGREN IIC IN HER
EM CIRN NNS ALK WITH THE
LIKELY BE REQUESTED?E T TH
MESSAGES THAREELETED WERINY COUS
OF TELEPHOS TO
WHEE SAYHAASTI OF TH
SE
IF YOU GONE
U NTONEY'LSA
G BACKED
LIKE C
UHIFORE YOUIGRATE.
AND THAT BORNEUTS OF
WHICH WTCNSRUMP THESEIC
EFEME HI
TO CIT
THE IMMEDIATE RESP T
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
E RNEDOD
EDIATEA
REALITY AND
NDF ,  IKE TOTYOF THEILETTO
RHE NAAST THS LIKE
I GETOSKS FILLEIN.ALOUR NE
ATLANTA IC
NDICTEASEORGIA
E IN E
SO WHAT DOES THIS TELL Y A
D. OL MENT AS OPPOSED TO JUST
TH, MEWOD >> WELN AN INS , HE TN
TATIFIEDT THEY HAVE  B FOR
CONSPIRACY D AMPAIGNIE IF
E E  SHEBE
IR THAT'S WHAT'S GOITHATWHAT'SG
FULTOD E ITTEE,
CE
POTEERTHRO
ELWOULD THER SHARING O
IN THESE
HAPPENING SIMU
HERI
UNITED STATES
RTJUIC TFE
SO I EXPECT AT A OES
AGENCIES, THE FE